75 percent of black kids in california
cannot read at state levels of
proficiency
50 of all kids in the public sector
public universities in california k-12
cannot read at state levels of
proficiency
i went to crenshaw high school that was
a the school that was
featured in boys in the hood i just
checked yesterday
two percent are math proficient and it's
a school that's dominated by the gang
called the crips
who the hell sends their kid to a high
school where only two percent are math
proficient
and a school that's dominated by crips
if they can get out the majority of
inner city parents black and brown both
want choice
but they keep pulling that lever for
democrats that don't give them choice
average price in california is 150 more
than the average price in america
and according to leo haney and one of
the many experts that i've
interviewed on my radio show over the
years he's brilliant econ professor at
ucla
he says houses in california are 50 more
than they would be but for the
environmental laws
and the extremists that have been using
them to stop construction of housing
which is why we have a housing shortage
it's why so many young people are
leaving
california going to places like
tennessee and florida
and texas there's a magazine they've
called ceo magazine don't know if you're
familiar with it they've been around
17 years and based upon things like
taxes spending
unfunded pension liabilities the power
of public sector unions
and the degree to which the business
climate is friendly or not friendly
california has been rated number 50 of
all 50 states for the entire 17 years
ceo magazine has been published
it is outrageous and this guy is doing
nothing at all about it
okay so that story starts however with
your dad coming out here because things
were better out here
what went wrong here and when did it get
wrong and did something
snap you think in the last two years
because of lockdown that
really like pushed it over the edge well
yeah to answer the latter part of your
question it was a lockdown because of
the way gavin newsom imposed these
mandates
against science and the way the teachers
union
kept getting paid while telling kids not
to go back to in-school learning even if
the cdc said it was okay
75 percent of black kids in california
cannot read at state levels of
proficiency
50 of all kids in the public sector
public universities in california k-12
cannot read at state levels of
proficiency
i went to crenshaw high school that was
a the school that was
featured in boys in the hood i just
checked yesterday
two percent are math proficient and it's
a school that's dominated by the gang
called the crips
who the hell sends their kid to a high
school where only two percent are math
proficient
and a school that's dominated by crips
if they can get out the majority of
inner city parents black and brown both
want choice but they keep pulling that
lever for democrats they don't give them
choice
explain that to me and when i've talked
to black media and i just did that the
other day in sacramento i said aren't
you tired
aren't you tired of the fact that 75
percent of black kids cannot read the
state level of
proficiency aren't you tired of the fact
that an la usd teacher los angeles
unified public school teacher
who has school-aged kids is twice as
likely as non-family
non-teaching families uh to put their
own kids in private school
forty-four percent of philadelphia
public school teachers dave with
school-age kids have their own kids in
private school
as opposed to ten percent of families
nationwide six percent of black families
nationwide
it's the equivalent of opening up a
restaurant putting up a sign and saying
come on in just don't eat the food
what are we talking about here aren't
you tired of this aren't you tired of
bad mouthing the cops and the cops are
pulling back
and the people who are hurt are the very
same people that the left claims that
they care about
aren't you tired of this so what is that
disconnect i mean i asked this to
basically all my guests at this point
what is the disconnect between voting
lefty policies
and then not understanding that it's
those policies that are doing all the
damage because
people by and large are not policy wonks
like you and i are they're not looking
at this they're working
yeah they're trying to put food on the
table so people leave and go to oregon
they go to places and all of a sudden
those states become more left-wing
and they bring their policies with them
because they haven't connected the dots
there's a reason why houses are so high
it's called sequa the california quality
environmental act
that basically stopped any project for
any reason for almost an indefinite
period of time
in preparing for this race i talked to a
lot of developers and contractors
and the stories they told me larry i had
a 2000
home development project all ready to
roll i got sold
i cut it down to a thousand i got sued i
cut it down to 500 i got sued now is 200
homes
22 years later i talked to one guy who
made all of his money
buying gas stations and when i say talk
to i'm
i'm on the phone trying to raise money
75 percent of being being a politician
is raising money
huh um and i call him and i
introduced myself i said my name's larry
yorkie who didn't know who i was i'm on
radio 30 years in california in every
major market you didn't know who i was
pretty ego settling a couple viral
videos with that dave rubin guy
tell me about it he didn't know who you
were either and i said haven't you seen
me on dave rubicoo
and um i said i said one of the things
i'm going to do
when i become governor is i'm going to
call a state emergency and i'm going to
suspend sequa
and he goes what's your name sequel was
suspended for the
construction of the sacramento king
stadium up in sacramento for a
billionaire somehow they waive sql but
for people that want
bill houses so the average person
leaving california doesn't realize
that stopping construction of course
means it's going to be a surplus a
a a a deficit of homes economics 101
supply and demand and as a result fewer
fewer supply the the demand goes up
and the prices go up so young people
can't get that starter home the way my
father was able to do
with an eighth grade education and
people are leaving they don't understand
the connection between
the declining public schools and the
fact that you literally cannot fire a
teacher
derek chauvin by the way however you
feel about how that trial turned out
had about 15 serious complaints against
him they couldn't get rid of them
same thing with teachers there are 300
000 public school teachers in the state
of california
i am told by experts that between five
and seven percent of them are
incompetent which means a minimum of
fifteen thousand need to be fired you
know we were fired last year
two two and took millions of dollars for
that to happen
and they end up in the worst schools i
subscribed to spectrum cable it used to
irritate me how it defaults to the la
times channel
i swear to you that's why i got rid of
cable because they would
every time you turn on the box
what you had the night before it's there
but after you're sitting there you're
captive and every now and then i'm
watching this stuff
and when i decided to run for office
it's local so i wanted to get more into
local issues
and the other day two or three days ago
there's this black woman who started her
own school
and it turns out two-thirds of black
parents do not want to send their kids
back to lausd
they've seen how bad the education was
because they were able to watch it
online and they are ticked off and they
believe there is systemic racism but not
the normal kind of systemic racism
because most of the teachers and the
administrators are black
right they believe the worst teachers
and the worst administrators end up
in the in the inner city schools where
they need the best teachers and the best
administrators and they believe that's
systemic racism
so they want out i'm the one that wants
to give you out
and but i'm an uncle tom and i'm a
sellout think about it
connect the dots all right there's a
reason for this okay so on the dots the
dots
i think in terms of the zeitgeist of
america have been being connected
because you've been talking about the
family stuff forever
and that you got to stop throwing money
at all these things there do seem to be
more
red-pilled former lefties like me that
perhaps because of the video that you
and i did where you beat me senseless
and
everyone's seen it already but but
people woke up
right so in that regard are you feeling
hopeful that maybe
in place in pockets of say the black
community that weren't uh open to these
ideas
i am absolutely hopeful i believe i can
explain things in ways that joe and joe
sinks back and can get again it's not
because they're stupid
it's because they're working they're
putting food on the table they're trying
to get that first starter home
but they don't realize that the
connection between this and all the
problems that they're complaining about
we talked about homelessness
what does gavin newsom and the democrats
want to do about homelessness build
homes
at a cost three four five times in what
the private sector could do a and b
not dealing with the underlying problem
why they're homeless in the first place
so even if they were
able to get up and go to the homes they
wouldn't stay meanwhile you're sending a
single to the other states cold weather
climates
i can go to california where the weather
is nice people are going to treat me
humanely and i get a free home come on
down
and that's what's happening i talked to
cops who tell me that many people on
skid row
aren't even from here yeah no we know
that they're coming now so when you see
that places like venice that was
used to venice beach was the coolest
gorgeous place all in
trendy bohemian it's a disaster right
now drugs everywhere
needles everywhere and one of the
reasons is because of proposition 47
that the voters in california foolishly
voted for
which meant that if you still at 9 50 or
less
by the way you can do it every day yeah
you're not going to go to jail because
you'll get
you're you'll be committing a
misdemeanor and they catch you they'll
give you a ticket the whole point was
and it was a
legitimate point was to get people in
treatment because many people who are
stealing
are still in to support their meth habit
but you take away the
the stick of going to jail there's no
reason to go to rehab
so the cops are saying get up and go to
rehab fu why should i go what are you
going to do to me nothing
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell